c'était il ya 50 ans le 30 janvier 1972
qui a tort civils sont tués lorsque des
soldats britanniques ouvrent le feu sur
une manifestation pacifique
et c'est dans une irlande du nord qui
n'a pas oublié que des manifestants ont
retracé le trajet du tristement célèbre
bloody sunday le dimanche sanglant avant
de leur rendre hommage
[Musique]
l'huître et denis bradley et survivants
de cette tragédie
cinquante ans après il se souvient
parfaitement du moment où tout a basculé
j'ai entendu des coups de feu et cela
m'a surpris et puis beaucoup de gens se
sont mis à courir
je me souviens que je me tenais ici et
qu'un groupe de personnes est arrivée en
portant un corps un jeune homme
gravement blessé aux mains
ce dimanche-là près de 20000
manifestants catholiques protester
contre la loi sur l'internement décrété
peu avant elle permettait d'emprisonner
une personne sans jugement préalable une
mesure dirigée contre les catholiques
république est victime depuis des années
de discrimination arbitraire en termes
d'emploi de logement et de justice
s'en est suivi cet épisode sombre de
l'histoire nord-irlandaise opposant les
républicains catholiques partisans de la
réunification de l'irlande et les
loyalistes protestants attaché au métier
sous la couronne britannique
l'ondh a présenté des excuses mais aucun
soldat n'a encore été condamnés
[Musique]
le groupe i où tout a d'ailleurs rendu
hommage aux victimes les deux leaders
bono et viège ont interprété leurs
célèbres chansons sonnent les bloody
sunday
si daniel 4 joa du canada montréal
non
[Musique]